i want to talk a little bit more about
what you're you're doing because i think
um a lot of these issues we're talking
about um
like the broken system broken politics
the broken media
um i think a lot can be fixed with
education
um i know that sounds like a fun
catch-all but um i think the root of
most of our problems is
look you don't educate your populace you
don't give people access to good
education
um starts up the fri start thing things
start to fritz
um and it's tough to expect people to
think logically when they're both
poor and uneducated right um and that's
that's frustrating um
well i'm gonna challenge that statement
a little bit i think that's kind of true
but i also think there's some
i mean the data shows that people are
people are generally
irrational right it's it's our deep yeah
you can be extremely educated
because i found some very smart educated
people
people just get into their zones into
their and it shuts off and they just
shut down and shut off so
a lot of dumb smart people yeah yeah
there's a whole bunch of people and i
think so
sadly if i can i would
i would i would i put these things in
three different buckets
right uh the power to change comes with
protests because you have to fight back
in order to make things happen
the protest doesn't matter until you
actually have policy
so it has to be tied to policy but you
also can't sustain policy
and protests won't matter unless you
actually have power
right and so like i think communities
have to have to
have to have to have to join together to
get more power uh
it comes with education because you need
education as a basis layer so education
has to be equitable
and there needs to be opportunities and
i can have a whole
i agree with you that education is very
important i just have a different reason
for it like i don't think people are
necessarily convinced
because they have education um or next
year
like just because we educate people
doesn't mean they're going to be
rational or not
i mean what happens and you're right
right i mean people people tend to be
the greatest indicator of someone voting
for
uh that last person in office who
clearly was
racist or or at least using racist
propaganda and doing things as divisive
as possible
saying misogynistic thing so you pick
your reasons for for not liking him
there's a whole lot of reason not to
like him
but um the single biggest indicator was
people living in non-diverse communities
that was it so like it's hard harder to
hate up close
right so oh my gosh yes right so like
it's you can it's easy to believe
stereotypes but when you actually get to
know people
it's a lot harder um so we have to
figure out how do we get more how do we
get
how do we get more opportunities to
connect people
how do we connect rural communities and
urban communities in a way that's
meaningful
how do we how do we i think how do we
expand access to
uh infrastructure in terms of not only
uh hopefully having
a you know high-speed rail that connects
us in different ways but also
infrastructure for the 21st century
building out
wi-fi and making sure that we that folks
have the the broadband
support in all their communities like
that i think doing that thing and
connecting people more the more people
can be isolated
you can give them all the education in
the world the more people are isolated
and they're in their corners the harder
it is i was working
in um in brooklyn um
at a a a lower income school and
a lot of the kids did not seem to have
um
kind of to your point like the why
they're in school like they're like
learning math
but why like what is this for um so i
get an a on a test for what to go to
college that seems unattainable
um are you i mean i'm over simplifying
it but that uh but that's very important
you're right i mean there's there's not
a practical application
like what is this what does this matter
in my life so we started doing business
competitions in these schools or bring
the kids to the office
it was like shark tank light where the
kids would create a new shoe for nike or
something like that
um and the biggest thing we found was
that the kids are like
it changed their their their trajectory
in their mind they're like well this is
why math matters because when lebron
james or seth curry whoever you know
nicki minaj is wearing those shoes
or doing her music video she's getting
paid for that someone's running the
numbers someone's designing the set
there's all these different things um
but i um i have it figured out um
like our org is growing it's great i do
think this is like a core to what's
missing education that like active
relevant learning piece
but i don't know how to do it at scale
um in that
um i'm curious your thoughts on
um how to get i know you've done a lot
of work with entities and businesses but
how to get
the kids that need this access and
frankly if they had the access
to you know a direct path to nike would
be kicking ass
at that firm they would kill to have
these kids ideas in many ways um
but aren't getting it and what i mean um
i mean it starts with wi-fi we're
talking about but things you've seen and
maybe even tell about some of the work
you're doing to kind of break those
barriers i think it's interesting
a scale is really tough um
it it it's going to be local solutions
in areas because
you have to be proximate to the area or
to the problem to really have
a long-term impact um i don't have the
answer to be
to be scalable i i yeah but but i do
know
that there are some things that have to
happen for it to work the things you're
talking about
the uh connecting uh learning to
to things that that kids understand and
can see and touch
uh really providing education that is
not just about
you know learning abstract points in
history
or pure memorization which i think is
almost a waste of a waste of our time uh
i don't think that's what should be done
uh i do think there needs to be a lot
more on how do we how do we get
how do we teach them heck things that
they can like editing
um how to code and beyond that
but before you get to that critical
thinking put them in situations about
yeah in a way that is uh real and and
and applicable like you did like if you
had a shark tank
thing and you made it apply and they got
a chance to do that the folks got a
chance to actually do internships i
found
if we can get more opportunities for uh
expert
experiential experiences where people
can actually go and have jobs
and and work with uh entrepreneurs
people in corporate america and you have
kids that normally wouldn't see that
they get that opportunity
those things change perspectives i mean
it starts with people changing
perspectives about what's possible
um and it has to be done at the local
level like i scaling it
i i don't know fully i just have an idea
of what has to happen
at local levels one of my biggest fears
right now is
the world is changing faster than it
ever has the world's always been
changing but now we're seeing that
change accelerate
and absolutely you're starting to see
game-changing technologies and they're
going to hit us faster so i think the
blockchain
um is one like massive example like deep
fakes i think 3d printing there's some
things that are going to start
accelerating and changing everything um
and obviously the internet has
done its number on us um yep it already
has changed how we think
oh yeah we're going that way and all
these kids are growing up i'm addicted
to the phones and adults addicted to
phones too it's not the kids fault um
and but my fear is
um so when this happens there's a
massive opportunity we're gonna have a
new market a new economy like all these
things gonna change very fast but
um if it's still the way we
are at are now you're gonna have the
wealthy the elite the powerful the
uber educated are gonna have access to
these new changes on the frontier
and who gets left behind the
marginalized communities communities
color but i mean by the numbers across
the board and so
my fear the example is like oh buy a
blockchain and bitcoin and these
cryptocurrencies are going to
democratize finance and do all these
great things you're right
but there's going to be the people that
actually could use the democratization
not get access to them um now
to me the simplest way to solve that is
actually your point like let's get wi-fi
everywhere so like the kid is coming
from a rough like the worst background
ever
like theoretically he or she is like
ability to at least have access
hypothetically to the treasures of the
internet and some of these crazy ideas
that are changing everything
um but that's obviously
oversimplification not the only thing
that needs to happen but thoughts on
[Music]
how we can get the right the communities
that need it would benefit most of it
into
crypto nfts like some of these cutting
edge tech whatever they may be
when i when i hear all of these uh
politicians and i hear them on the left
and the right
they focus on returning to things as
they were right
make america great again there's you're
conservative or you're rich you've got
something to conserve right right yeah
but a lot of people that are conserving
uh a past
that where america was the only dominant
superpower
where you know if it was just enough to
be
a white man and that's all you needed to
be and you can
use you can hang on to just that feeling
um
or or like we had just everything was
heavy manufacturing
uh that world's not coming back it's
never coming back so
we can't we we can't we can't recreate
the past but we can build a better
future as you say
and so our our policies need to be
thinking about what's coming next like
you you you really
talked about a lot of it but we know i
think i think the biggest
both threat and opportunity is
artificial intelligence uh it's
because that that that is that it that
is and is going to rapidly
change the the landscape of work and so
you know the question has to be what is
our policy going to be to deal with this
and and
and to make sure that we are doing
everything possible to
to get our get our citizens ready for
that economy
and that has to be our approach our
approach can't be we we're going to do
what we what we've done before because
ai and technology are moving things so
are moving so fast
uh that a whole bunch of people will be
displaced i i i'm hopeful that
folks will have will be able we'll
transition into new jobs that happen in
the industrial revolution but what
people don't talk about is there was a
20 or 30 year period where people were
massively displaced and it was a
horrible time
and so people never talk about they talk
about what happened
after we went through that they they the
benefits right
they talk about the benefits they don't
talk about the struggle to get to the
benefits they don't talk about the fact
that when we had all these robber barons
that we were
exploiting kids and that people were
working
like 15 hours a day and people were
dying all the time on the job and they
no one talks about that part right but
but what we had to do to make it better
is we obviously had unions we had people
had workers fight back we had child
labor every day became a holiday
because right massive strikes people
died yeah and we
created a economy that began to address
these concerns took us a long time to do
it
uh we can't take that long with
technology because it's gonna move so
much faster
and so we have to be more nimble so it's
not gonna so we have to have
and this this is very difficult because
often you have people in government that
have no idea
about technology and so they're creating
policies they have no idea
how to actually move it forward and then
you got a lot of technologists
that some of them are very well meaning
a lot of them just care about
becoming very very rich right and
nothing wrong with getting rich i
believe in capitalism but i believe in
in having a system that works for people
so uh
why i'm in entrepreneurship right now
and it's not to say i wouldn't get back
into
running public office at some point is
that i believe it's so hard to really
have that impact right now because
people
people's brains are just so shut off
right now i have a lot of people that i
can work with i say the same thing
that i'm saying to you right now as long
as i don't say i'm a democrat i'm
working in business people are all for
it like
but there's no real right so like so my
goal is to really
expand where i can with entrepreneurship
so uh
our platform disrupt art is looking to
use
uh art uh that is aimed towards social
impact so we wanna empower people that
are
in in marginalized communities to be
though they're gonna be the feature of
the platform uh
part of the platform is teaching these
artists to become better entrepreneurs
and we also want partnerships to to
promote uh
art that is about social impact art an
example one of the artists
that we that that that's going to come
up on our platform his name is uh
david bianchi he's a he's a big
well-known actor he's pretty well a
well-known actor spoken spoken word
artist
and he had an nft about george floyd and
gave all the money to that and i think
he
made like 20 they made like twenty
thousand dollars i mean there's a way
to connect and empower the community we
want to use the platform to do that
because the tech the technology is not
going anywhere there are people that
i know you're not one of those people
that say like well we just shouldn't do
these things i hear you
but artificial intelligence is coming
blockchain is here it's it's here
so the the question is how are we going
to use it in a way
that empowers people so i mean my job i
think is to try
is to use is to use my platform and use
the power
to help and empower more people that's
what we are hoping distinguishes disrupt
art
disrupt art.io now from other
other platforms they're about just
selling but we want to actually create a
platform that will have uh events and
accelerators that are helping
these artists but also eventually
entrepreneurs and others use the power
of technology
to help transform society
[Music]
you